[Applause]
this is the first movie where we
actually see the full body of the
xenomorphs actually running around
they're all really wow
dang that's a sam you're getting it to
wrap around these dudes look look how
much work this is wait they replace the
e.t with a c-g-e-t yeah i kind of want
to see that
thanks to the ridge wallet for
sponsoring this video stick around to
the end so you get 10 off
what's up guys welcome back to visual
effects artists react that's right it's
an og episode today with nico and ren
and myself today we have some incredible
clips for you i hope you enjoy i got
clips that these guys have never seen
before i got tasty clips they're going
to lose it dude i got tifo's clip i got
a natural t-pose in a movie
hey remember that time we put a t-pose
in our boss dynamics video yeah
remember the time that joe rogan thought
it was real yeah
twice
so we're gonna be looking at a movie
with some of the worst cgi ever made
because this is a movie that came out
before
cgi was really a thing
oh it's pretty rough that one shot in
particular was a little rough they're
all really wow
so up until this point all of the alien
shots we've seen were of a dude in a
suit or some sort of like stop-motion
thing this is the first movie where we
actually see the full body of the
xenomorphs actually running around
obviously we got some like classic 90s
compositing going on here where oh my
gosh and like it's like sliding around
they're like tracking the light decently
but it's just like weird circle bulbous
shape going on there for the head shadow
that's 100 hand roto that's a bezier
curve done like after effects or flame
or something i talked about the shadow
the shadow it's rough it is rough i mean
this is a situation where like i feel
like you got an artist not an old
machine and it's like you can do like
three things before it gets to be too
intense and you're like composite breaks
if you can't render it anymore so it's
important to note that there's not
really any cgi in this movie hey what's
the difference between visual effects
and cgi great question cgi is when you
are creating something with a computer
from scratch visual effects is basically
a broader term that can encompass
certain effects done on a computer but
also just visual trickery like you know
compositing film over itself so this is
a good example this is we're not looking
at cgi here this is the effects the
effects yeah all of the aliens that
you're seeing are actually rod puppets
these xenomorphs you're seeing are
literally like a third of the size of
the real thing and all of its limbs its
head its tail are attached to little
rods and you have like three to five
dudes literally just going
murmur but it was also a huge challenge
for them to actually do all of this
stuff because yes you have the blue
background for the alien but the rods
aren't blue and even if they were
you know sometimes the rods are in front
of the alien and what that means is that
they had to go in and manually like
rotoscope out the rods from the alien on
top of keying it out but they actually
had some pretty fancy stuff for actually
filming the movie though because david
fincher didn't want to have like static
shots he didn't want to have tripod
shots so we wanted to have a moving
camera and so what they ended up
developing and building for this movie
was a special type of motion control
system one that was able to record the
motion as a regular operator moved the
camera we're talking like dollying left
and right tilting the camera up and down
panning left and right those were all
recorded into a recorder that they could
then take and replicate with motors at
one third scale essentially all the
technology from star wars but like
executing at pretty much the the peak of
what that type of tech can do
it's it's just so crazy how like janky
this stuff looks compared to the first
two alien movies i want to talk about
what that is why are people's brains
going oh this looks bad and it's the
edges of the alien it's kind of a matte
line issue like here you can really see
some there's like this black line
normally we see that and that's just
kind of like bad matting we've talked
about that classic style of composite in
the past but for me it almost looks like
it's like a negative light wrap you know
like it feels like that dark line is
eating into the alien layer yeah i mean
you have like 10 different things that
influence your edges you have your
actual onset lighting you have the
reflective properties of the surface and
what's behind it you have the actual
matte edges as you mentioned if you get
a shirt her shirt literally gets
brighter right on the edge there as well
the pole behind her you know that gets
brighter on the edge as well but
xenomorph doesn't get brighter on the
edge it's probably all the edge work
they're trying to do to get it to blend
in like i personally think it's probably
part of their like their rudimentary d
spill process because where we see it
the most is on this ultra like round
object since we're looking at a rounded
object we're basically getting this like
sliver line that's bouncing the light of
whatever is behind it so how do you like
de-spill that stuff because you know
there's plug-ins you can use for after
effects yeah why didn't they use those
plug-ins back then spill it like
and i don't know how this is done when
it's shot on film but i would imagine if
we saw what this looked like without
that black line it'd probably be like
blue yeah i think you're right it's like
they're trying to remove the blue but
didn't quite remove the actual
brightness value because the reflection
idea we're talking about is called
fresnel basically what it means is that
the more parallel you get to a surface
the more reflective it becomes and if
you're looking like perfectly parallel
along a surface it's almost going to be
perfectly mirror-like and so what we're
seeing there instead of a dark edge we
should see a very bright edge and we're
not so our brains just subconsciously
are seeing something that is wrong
that looks really good that looks good
okay yeah that was an addition that was
made in 2003 over 10 years later
that's why it looks so good yeah and
they tried doing it with actual puppet
work here and it just didn't quite make
it in time for the initial cut of the
movie so when they did the revised
version over 10 years later they added
the cg little
cheating little baby thing you should
have done it the same way also for the
record i was looking at some before and
afters on the new 4k release and a lot
of the edges and the contrast and color
matching has been fixed and they didn't
go back and just replace the alien with
a cgi alien like they did for you know
et for instance
wait they replaced et with a c-g-e-t
sorry
i just
i kind of want to see that
[Music]
oh no no
they made him go bowing even harder
because previously he's just like
gliding through the grass you know with
a little wiggle wobble now he's bounding
[Music]
oh whoa whoa whoa there's the cgi at
first i made them cgi you're right it
feels over animated and i feel like this
is a representation of early animation
where they realize wait we can do all
kinds of stuff we can actually squish
his cheeks out and make him have a
little bit more character but et in our
heads is still that initial original et
that was a little bit more stiff because
it was a real
[Music]
puppet this is an interesting shot
because it's like clearly all right
here's a kid on a blue screen and then
they have your aerial footage behind
them and so obviously there's like a
little bit of bump and wobble that they
can't quite account for you know in the
track there so it's not totally
stabilized so i'm curious though like do
you think they like found the original
like stock of the guy on the blue screen
you know and like tracked them onto a
smoother shot i mean also the aerial
footage is whiter in the new shot so i
wonder if they found the original
footage and they had cropped it and now
it's uncropped that's what it looks like
to me in the sense that it looks like
they managed to actually get the
original stock of the visual effects
elements here and then like re-stabilize
stuff and properly track it back in and
add two additional bikes because i can
totally get behind that kind of like
20th anniversary re-release mega edition
stuff where it's like guys check this
out we have the original stuff here and
we can actually do this shot yeah we can
do the composition like there's it's
like it's an objective better kind of
that's truly a remaster that's taking
the original footage and remastering it
like imagine if you like listen to a
beatles remastered album but it's just
new singers
the beatles 100th anniversary edition is
like so we improved all the singing on
the songs
yeah i could see this being like early
enough and cgi becoming good that steven
spielberg would be excited about this
like yeah let's let's make a cgi et and
like it does look good but now
another 20 years on top of this where
it's like these are both in our like
history now it's like look tell me what
you guys think like would you prefer the
jank and the charm of the original or
would you prefer like a version of the
movie you can watch where you're not
being distracted by old special effects
i guess it's really not about me it's
about the children what do you think
children in 2002 thought of this
[Music]
versus in the 80s does it still fill
them with wonder and excitement because
i think that's the metric to judge it by
somebody in the comments of one of our
previous videos mentioned there's a
t-pose in the original hellboy you're
telling me someone dropped in like a 3d
model of a character but forgot to
animate it and then it made it to the
final film well let's just real quick
define what the t-pose is so when you
have a character and you're modeling the
character you want to rig it up and move
it you generally model it's like the
limbs are away from each other in a
standard position so when you put a
skeleton in there like if my arms were
like this when i modeled my character
and i had to put a skeleton in there
like everything's all stuck together and
too close to each other like at least
over here my left hand and my right hand
are far away so i put a bone in my hand
it knows to attach to this hand and not
to all the rest of the mesh when you
have an animation glitch and your
character loses animation they return to
their default pose which is the t-pose
hence why there's a t-pose in the boston
dynamics short
yeah all right let's just let's just see
i want to see if we can spot it
that's all for you
pinhead
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait that's a cg hellboy in that shot no
he's not cg you're just looking at a
compositing glitch
oh it's it's oh he's not a t-pose he's
still holding his hand
it's almost as if like the shot finished
and then they just took the beginning
few frames for the end frame i bet you
some of those things like when you run
out of footage you can set the program
to like use the first frame hold the
last frame ping pong back and forth it
probably just defaulted back to the
first frame and helped like it was like
set to like a loop mode by default so
when they extended it it goes back to
the beginning of the shot
oh my god
okay so that's not actually a t-pose
that's just a funny like footage glitch
also it's closer to a why pose let's be
honest here
depends how you draw your t's hey
everybody our channel was hacked and it
was deleted so we gotta start from zero
so consider subscribing
as i'm filming this episode our channel
was hacked and then terminated so you
know what that means it means we lost a
lot of subscribers so if you're not
subscribed you should definitely
subscribe right now because we got a lot
of numbers to make up for and if you are
subscribed just make sure you still are
subscribed because who knows what
happened on youtube
people are kind of ragging on miss
marvel let's be real it's a tv series it
actually looks amazing for a tv series
now that disney's like doing marvel tv
series they're trying to hit this bar of
like quality that the marvel movies have
and it's a really challenging thing to
do this shot let's watch it it's not
flawless or perfect but after we watch
it i want you guys to try to figure out
what's going on and how did they make
the shot
i'm getting like cg person vibes the
animation is pretty solid for the most
part for the most part yeah there's like
a couple moments where she's doing a
whole bunch and that's all having to be
animated but like the thing that gave it
away to me was the final like second
where she's no longer on those things
and she's on the ground there's
something uncanny she does that really
weird like yes but she like floats over
and like floats back and like her center
of gravity doesn't change enough for
like the shot you know this is a super
challenging type of animation to do
because what comes first is it chicken
or the egg is it do you animate the foot
pad or the character first because
they're both intertwined from an
animation standpoint it's a simulation
within a simulation how do you handle
that timing of when something like drops
versus when the character reacts your
character stands on a seesaw do you
animate the see-saw and your character
adjusting to it or do you animate your
character and the see-saw adjusting to
the character yeah if you have someone
like balancing what comes first in the
animation process that being said though
like overall like it is generally
working except for then the part when
you know she hops off and you're like oh
okay i get it here's my my takeaway on
this like a lot of people were
criticizing this for being janky and
like it's a little janky because like
it's super ambitious like how do you
make a character walk and run on things
that are in the air now they went with
the motion capture route the thing is
with motion capture you still can't do
impossible things so they did it in
chunks like they did a little bit here
and they set up new platforms they did
it there they said new platforms they
did it there and you can see these
transitions now where you have like
flawless motion like when she jumps up
onto like that air conditioning stack
right there you get kind of this like
morph or like group actually pose it
moves to the next pose so they're
blending different motion capture chunks
when you go from reality to hand
animation and back to reality our brains
are just so good at picking that up that
we see it yeah that's exactly the
problem i have with this shot is that
it's just it's very slow long take and
it gives us the opportunity to really
scrutinize it now they probably could
have gotten away with it no one would
have said anything about this shot if
they would have just cut this shot a
second before it actually cut and we
didn't get the hundred percent tan
animation janky yes bits on the ground
or did you just punch into like a
close-up or something of that final
reaction and cut yeah cut on the landing
so i mean it looks great for a tv show
and for the volume of effect shots in
this it's wonderful but also they're
pushing it so hard that things do break
a little bit and it's just a testament
to the challenge of trying to make hand
animation look real
[Music]
wow i mean that's cool looks insanely
good that was pretty sweet dang look at
them sam wow what's that called
elephant's toothpaste yeah that's a sam
that's a really nice dang i mean in fact
they like different material properties
in the foam there's like parts that's
like liquid and there's parts that are
foamy do you getting it to wrap around
these dudes look look how much work this
is i mean those are cg dudes though no
they were real those are the collision
models okay so what you're saying is
that was real footage of those dudes
coming out of the doorway but someone
had to go through and essentially
rotomation right yeah yeah collision
models what we're saying is that they
needed something to interact with the
fluid sim because the fluid sim is
definitely not real but the soldiers are
real so they have to basically replicate
the soldier's motion with very highly
detailed 3d models so that the fluid
going around it actually has something
to bounce off of and stick yeah i'm just
saying this is insanely good there is
practical look look at their feet there
they do have practical foam they hit him
with a little bit that's all practical
right there and in the final shot it's
not really used because it all gets
covered you know i commend the
filmmakers for that at least forward
thinking they're like we got to have
something here yeah obviously there's no
practical way to film a sequence like
this without like completely making your
set unusable also that foam is
incredibly hot so we're seeing steam
come off of it because it's boiling hot
exactly yeah it's an exothermic reaction
like you can't for safety reasons have
someone just swimming around in that
stuff so miss marvel burned these guys
alive
i mean
they're all horribly dying yeah they're
all getting steamed up and they're
turning into little crabs yeah chemistry
[Music]
that looks really good it's a very
simple shot actually at the end of the
day the technique is simple the
execution is simple i wouldn't call it
simple what do you mean okay so it's a
cgi shot at the halfway point the people
getting flung around the car their cgi
characters have been animated to fly
over the car but the way the shot is lit
makes it really easy to make that cgi
look realistic it's you know really
strong harsh key light from the side
you're not dealing with crazy surface
properties that you have to try to like
show under a bunch of lighting it's dark
with just one bright light off to the
side the people who are real at the
beginning of the shot are still comped
into it the actual bass footage which is
real is of the car entering the scene
and the camera guy being like oh gotta
chase the action back to this guy but
those people aren't in the shot they're
being added back in even though they are
also filmed the thing that makes it
really really good is the animation
whoever animated the body is flying over
the car nailed that aspect of it like
especially like the guy in the orange
jacket you see how he gets forward
momentum but then his leg goes down and
catches the ground and creates that like
kind of friction which then stops his
momentum allowing the car to continue
over him there's a lot of details that
cue you into it being real their actions
take note that one person is being hit
immediately and the other one has that
moment to like still take two steps
really really good directing there good
mind's eye imagination of what's gonna
happen which is crucial to making cool
vfx shots and also like the stuff that
goes flying into the air so you see the
bandana yeah i love the bandana falls
slowly compared to everything else it's
those little things that are just really
nice about it i do like the other guy
spits when he gets hit though it's like
a cold environment and you see that like
breath of exhaled air shoot out which is
like a really tiny tiny detail but like
it's yeah i don't know it's it's
fantastic the motion of the suspension
it doesn't look like just a car just
skidding you know it feels like we got
some elevation here the car is actually
running over sandbags that's all it is
it's just running over cinema sandbags
probably have something lying in the
corner or this one right here it's a bag
filled with sand it's a sandwich that
felt like you literally just a dude
yeah it's you see it's proof it's
actually made out of sand it actually
has sand in it yeah they just put a big
stack of sand bags which you have on
every film set and they ran over them
with the car we did that yeah remember
effect was straight up me copying this
effect just i didn't use a cgi character
going flying we just had you on the
ground instead but the angle the
technique is all the same minus the cgi
guy's flying i just are not saying you
specifically saw this and you're like
i'm gonna do this for the yes
[Laughter]
like john burton said you sell your
effect right and this is perfect selling
the effect they start with real people
and then when the car hits them when
it's hidden from your eye like a
magician slide a hand they transition to
the cgi they have the real elements
there you have a real car hitting real
bumps you have real dust added dust and
cg bodies and boom got yourself a
wonderful shot
run
do you feel like we maybe uh cut things
a little short here we'll head over to
corridor digital.com where we have
extended editions of these episodes
they're awesome check it out everybody
in the office could use a little ridge
wallet makeover courtesy of the ridge
wallet hey chase how's your wallet
treating you these days you got a dad
wallet this is totally a dad well look
at this thing look at the size of this
thing
it's a chunky little wallet right here
man look at this nice fresh metal case
dude that is beautiful this is yours if
you like it you pack all your cards in
there let me see how it feels in the
back pocket
no more bump you
come here oh my god dude oh no
oh son look at that griffin i want to
give you a new wallet this little thing
has a wallet yeah they say the walls are
built with such good quality materials
they have a lifetime warranty on them
seriously and if you don't like it
within 45 days you can send it back to
get all your money back seems like a
no-brainer man i mean it's a pretty good
deal this thing looks sweet dude i store
my wallet in my fanny pack mainly
because so you're rocking a dad wallet
right there my man hey you know how like
modern cards have like rfid chips in
them that you can use to like tap your
card and charge your money look like
some stealthy guy comes up on the street
and goes like whoop and like kiss your
offid chip well right now i'm using rfid
protectors
yeah that is very important to me he has
every individual card currently wrapped
what is this these
protectors
wallet you don't need rfid protectors
because it's built into the wallet
here's your new ridge wall yeah dude
save yourself for me yeah
this is nice okay thanks rich wallet i'm
gonna stop you right there though
because i
do not have a dad wallet i've got a very
thin one as you can see what is that so
yeah that's like an uncle wallet it's a
it's an uncle wall it's a weird uncle
wall is it curved
after sitting on it for years
yes it is well did you know that every
dollar you spend on ridge.com to buy a
wallet up till september 30th enters you
into sweepstakes to win a ford bronco if
you don't afford bronco you can just win
75k in cash instead what you can pick
yeah you can pick
i feel like you might like the option
wow to have a cool wallet wow look at
how thin it is if you don't like that
color they have over 30 others on the
website ridge.com slash quarter
or use corridor crew as your coupon code
for that same 10 off there's links in
the description below i use it i guess i
don't know how to endorse it beyond that
this is my wallet go check it out
richard.com
i want to hear about your glitches and
movies what little glitches have you
noticed weird funky little things like
cowboy t-posing please consider leaving
a comment down below let us know that
was a lot of fun thank you for sticking
around and watching despite our channel
not currently existing in this moment
hopefully it's back i'm assuming it's
back you're watching it thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week bye
[Music]